Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today we are going to open an AI-powered hair
salon.
How cool is that.
But, how?
Well, we recently looked at this related technique
from NVIDIA that is able to make our rough
drawings come to life as beautiful photorealistic
images.
In goes a rough drawing, and out comes an
image of this quality.
And it processes changes to the drawings with
the speed of thought.
You can even request a bunch of variations
on the same theme, and get them right away.
So here is a crazy idea - how about doing
this with hair styles?
Just draw them, and the AI puts it onto the
model and makes it look photorealistic.
Well, that sounds like science fiction, so
I will believe it when I see it.
And, this new method claims to be able to
do exactly that, so, let’s see the pros
first.
This will go in, and this will come out.
How is that even possible?
Well, all we need to do is once again, produce
a crude drawing that is just enough to convey
our intentions.
We can even control the color and the length
of the hair locks, or, even request a braid,
and all of these work pretty well.
Another great aspect of this technique is
that it works very rapidly, so we can easily
iterate over these hair styles, and if we
don’t feel like our original idea will be
the one, we can refine it for as long as we
please.
The AI too works with the speed of thought.
One of the best aspects of this work.
You can see an example here.
This also does not look right…yet, but this
quick iteration also means that we can also
lengthen those braids in just a moment.
And, yes, better!
So, how does it perform compared to previous
techniques.
Well, let’s have a look together!
This is the input hairstyle, and a matte telling
the AI where we seek to place the hair, and,
let’s see the previous methods.
The first two techniques are very rough, this
followup work is significantly better than
the previous ones, but it is still well behind
the true photograph for reference.
This is much more realistic.
So, hold on to your papers, and let’s see
the new technique.
Now you’re probably thinking Károly…what’s
going on?
Why is the video not changing?
Is this an error?
Well, I have to tell you something.
It’s not an error.
What you are looking at now is not the reference
photo.
No-no.
This is the result of the new technique.
The true reference photo is this one.
That is a wonderful result.
The new method understands not only the geometry
of the hair better, but also how the hair
should play with the illumination of the scene
too.
I am a light transport researcher by trade,
and this makes me very, very happy.
So much so, that in some ways, this technique
looks more realistic than the true image.
That is super cool.
What a time to be alive!
Now, not even this technique is perfect.
Even though the new method understands geometry
better than its predecessors, we have to be
careful with our edits, because geometry problems
still emerge.
Look here.
Also, the other issue is that the resolution
of the generated hair should match the resolution
of the underlying image.
I feel that these is usually a bit more pixelated.
Now note that these kinds of issues are what
typically get improved from one paper to the
next, so, you know the deal, a couple more
papers down the line, and I am sure, these
edits will become nearly indistinguishable
from reality.
As you see, there are still issues, the results
are often not even close to perfect, but,
the pace of progress in AI research is nothing
short of amazing.
With this, we can kind of open an AI-powered
hair salon, and some cases will work, but
soon, it might be that nearly all of our drawing
will result in photorealistic results that
are indistinguishable from reality.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!